اوه ماي جاد
[موسيقى]
هي الحياه ما بتكمل
انا موجوده بس انا غير شخص الشخص يلي كان
قبل
بيموت يعني ما في ام تخسر ابنه غير ما
هيدا الشخص يلي هي بتكونوا بموت معه
وقتها
كانت كتير صغيره تعيش اول شغله انت لحالي
هو اذا ما عشت انا اكيد راح انتحر
الحافز اكيد هي انه بنتي
وبذات الوقت كمان انه انا بدي طالب
بالعداله لابني اذا قضيه مثل هاي انطمست
وما صار فيها حقيقه ولا في عداله الشعب
اللبناني لكنه شو عنده امل اول هو اجتنا
هي من بورن هي اكيد الكسندرا
والعنقلها ثالث سبب
هو الشعب
الياس كان عمره 15 سنه وكان بينوفمبر رح
يصيروا 16
كان عنده احلام
وكان شاب كتير بسامح ما عنده قلبه كتير
طيب بس كمان ذكي ووتيه وعشان غير اقول انه
يعني كل الام بتكون كتير محظوظه وقتها
يكون عندها ابن مثل الياس
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كانت تحب بحب الحياه كانت تحب السباحه كنت
تحب الغنى كانت تلعب
لونها المفضل
بحكي كتير
هو معنا
نعيش بدونه اكيد
[موسيقى]
لانه مش بس خساره بنت صارت بنت وغضب وقهر
كن هون سوا
انا هذا النشاط
امن انه عليك
جسديا بس روحيه
جانا بيتنا من شهرين
[موسيقى]
لسبب واحد هو انه هيدا البيت اليكساندرا
وكل كل ذكرياتنا
[موسيقى]
انا بتوجه لكل الامهات يلي
خسروا اولادهم ما يحسوا حالهم لحالهم ابدا
وكمان بقول له انه قد ما فيه كرمال
اولادها الباقيين كمان هن بحق لهم انه
يعيشوا
وبحقق لهم حياه عاديه طبيعيه
ولكل الامهات اللبنانيه يلي عم بيعانوا
هلا
طالما اولادكم حتكون ما تياسوا كل شي
بيمرق الشيء الوحيد اللي ما بيمرق
هو لما تخسروا اولادكم